so we have this horribly embarrassing
faux pas of Donald Trump starting to
badger people at the NATO summit and say
Russia is holding Germany captive and
then after this goes on we now have this
going in the direction that is exactly
where many people predicted it would go
which is that Donald Trump is
threatening to pull the United States
out of NATO altogether we've seen this
very up-and-down relationship between
Trump and NATO first it wasn't really
clear Trump knew what NATO actually was
it's actually still not completely clear
that he does it doesn't seem that he
knows who does what for whom does he
want to stay in does he want to get out
he initially made some anti NATO
comments including during the
presidential debates with Hillary
Clinton or maybe even the Republican
primary debate then later he said no we
want to be a part of NATO and then now
reportedly making threats for the United
States to go it alone leaving NATO
altogether so let's kind of build this
up so we all are on the same page what
is NATO NATO is a Treaty Organization
based on a an agreement from the late
1940s I think 1949 and it now includes
29 countries in North America and Europe
and the main point of it is what's
called collective defence what the NATO
member countries agree to do is mutually
defend each other when there if and when
there are attacks from external
countries countries that are not part of
the 29 countries so if one member
country is attacked like Germany the
United States is saying as part of this
NATO agreement we will come to Germany's
defense we don't need to get into all
the details but needless to say Trump's
big gripe with NATO has been that some
countries aren't paying their fair share
and as Trump describes it this is
because there are these spending targets
that countries are supposed to aspire to
they're not binding in reality and Trump
doesn't like that some countries
including Germany haven't increased
their NATO contributions as much as
Trump believes that they are actually
bound to do and reports are that Trump
completely derailed the meeting just
just hours ago in the early afternoon
Central European Time very very early in
the morning
and started making demands which
depending on which version of the story
you believe might include a demand that
members report to trump by January how
they are going to reach their spending
targets can you imagine Trump showing up
and saying everybody here report to me
by January when you're gonna spend more
money on this other reports include that
Trump threatened to quote do our own
thing or to quote go it alone if things
aren't to his liking by some completely
arbitrary date that he appears to be
trying to set
he was later asked did you threaten to
pull out of NATO or was that not what
you meant to do he didn't answer that
but he said he believes if he wanted to
pull out of NATO unilaterally that he
would be able to do it without getting
congressional approval this is an
absolute train wreck this is first of
all Trump bullying who the eff is Trump
quite frankly to start making these
demands and to take over the summit with
these completely bogus and arbitrary
impositions of requirements on the other
countries number two this is
particularly dangerous because Trump's
followers are clueless about most of the
stuff
Trump has strong opinions on so like
trade is a good example Trump knows
nothing about trade his supporters
seemingly know just as little during the
campaign Trump espoused an unbelievable
amount of uninformed trade rhetoric
which actually succeeded at convincing
his followers that he knows what he's
doing he then gets into office starts a
trade war with our allies that he can't
win and his supporters actually think
that this is good they think that this
is going to be a good thing it's the
same thing that's likely to happen here
Trump picks on NATO during the campaign
something he and his followers know very
very little about he will now say hey I
might pull out and I can pull out
unilaterally if I want to and his
supporters will of course a great do it
you're you're the boss here don't be
pushed around pull out of NATO and then
of course what you have to remember is
that no one would like the United States
to leave NATO more than who Vladimir
Putin and Russia the United States
leaving NATO even just making the threat
to leave NATO even saying if I wanted to
pull out I could do it just on my say-so
this is what Putin wants and huge
coincidence it's not Sri Lanka
that wants the United States out of NATO
it's not Equatorial Guinea or New
Zealand Russia would love the United
States out of NATO just a coincidence
right I mean it's never one of those
other countries and lastly there's the
legal question can Trump leave NATO
unilaterally unclear I'm hopeful that we
won't actually need to dig that deep on
that issue because I'm hoping Trump
isn't actually going to try to do it but
legal opinion is divided and if Trump
did need congressional approval you can
bet that a really great thing to stop
him from getting that would be voting in
2018 voting in November of 2018 so it is
yet another reason to vote in November
if you're concerned about the anti NATO
stuff that is going on embarrassment
after embarrassment
during this NATO summit send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
fruit or the tour is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board politics sports
so much more you wager on predictions
about real world events using fruit ORS
in-game fake currency and you earn more
of this currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on youtube and you
can sign up now at futurecom and start
making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm